they're the courts that decide whether a
child can stay with their parents that
rule on divorce adoption forced marriage
but family courts are notoriously secret
now the most senior family judge who
very rarely gives interviews wants to
change that
i've grasped the nettle and my proposal
is that the court should be open
for reporting so that journalists can
now attend any family court hearing and
report all that they see and hear
private information still can't be
reported but sir andrew wants more
anonymized judgments made available
people involved in cases to be able to
talk to journalists an overhaul of the
closed system that has existed for so
long for a court to take a child away
from parents
in care proceedings and for that child
to be adopted for life
is i think the most important and
serious decision that can be made and
the public have a legitimate interest in
understanding how that decision is made
and whether the courts are approaching
it in a way that commands public respect
and approval
so many cases are dealt with in the
family courts from divorce to child
custody to trans issues it is a highly
significant moment something that people
have been campaigning for for decades
but there's of course still a balance to
be struck between openness and privacy
maxine went through the family courts to
take over parental responsibility for
her niece she hopes greater transparency
will build confidence you trust the
system but actually
it doesn't quite always work out that
way
i have seen changes i have seen some
improvements and but i do feel there's
still a long way to go
with the system a very long way to go
attempts to modernise the family courts
have failed in the past these
recommendations may well need to go
through parliament
but the change that so many wanted is
now backed at the highest level
the basic principles here one is that
the judge is in charge and can apply
reporting restrictions to ensure
anonymity um secondly
the
uh if the journalists get it wrong there
will be a contempt of court but the real
winners here will be the public there is
a real
importance for justice to be seen to be
done
it is an important moment for
journalists but this sir andrew says is
about confidence in the system openness
that will help the people that use these
courts ali fortescue sky news